tolto il capitolo Murri ehm parlando
quindi dello youtuber migliore d'Italia
che esista cioè io questo youtuber ha
fatto tanta Gavetta tanta Gavetta e voi
non sapete o meglio i più temerari
sapranno perché c'è chi mi segue da una
vita che io ai tempi ho fatto un film
che faceva cagare
No non sto parlando di ieri sera sto
parlando di un altro film andavo alle
medie c'era questa attività che si
chiamava fare cinema neanche cinema fare
cinema Il film si chiama vive in quattro
terzi Tra l'altro vivere l'amore che
meraviglia Sì aspetta di crescere che
poi sono cazzi
e non ritorna più Voglio vedere Non vedo
l'ora Ci sono io sono in mezzo Eccolo
qua da Che sorriso quel maledetto
sorriso
[Musica]
l'ho visto nel bagno delle ragazze
Semplice alcuni si mettono la parrucca
altri la gonnellina Gabrieli Zac Efron
due uno dei miei migliori amici Gabri
che non ti posso guardare
il travestimento per entrare nel bagno
delle ragazze Scusatemi Ecco no
già il fiore sta morendo e non ho fatto
niente che capelli mia madre mi faceva
parliamone gran transizione complimenti
ma fatelo partire almeno da un po' più
lontano Si vede lontano un chilome Marco
Marco parti da lontano da fuori no si
vede che sei ferma e sta aspettando il
via Si vede Vabbè ma guarda guarda ma
come mi come mi vestivo cos'è cos'è
cos'è sta roba cos'è
[Musica]
nano
mia mamma e tagliati 'ste unghie man
mano dove toccare forse il caldone della
profezia davvero non capisco perché ce
l'hai con me
Com'è che è in Game Therapy sono
peggiorato era meglio qua Robe di Kappa
tua sorella non mi interessa Dopotutto
ben cinque anni in più di lei adesso 5
anni possono non sembrare che anche ma
vedrai fra qualche tempo
palese che io stia guardando fuori che
aspetto il tipo che mi dice la battuta
la battuta
Ecco lei avrà 95 anni io non avrò ben
100 ma poi guarda c'è Vi prego ragazzi
allora io avevo provato a fare sta roba
che erano era un precursore di Cristiano
Ronaldo Cioè praticamente mi ero fatto i
cosi dei capelli Cioè tipo mi ero rasato
qua può non esistere sto video Vi prego
quando di lei avranno 95 anni io non
avrò ben 100 ma che calcolo da
trogloditi Cosa vuol dire quindi io non
posso stare con una 2000 adesso chi è
che transizione che non è non esiste No
Gabri No no no non mi fare Stai fermo
che Ma come cazzo facevi ad avere i
capelli Cioè io veramente no Aspetta ti
chiamo oltre la dea Ecco ti posso far
vedere una cosa che ti svolta la
giornata posso vai
uguale
[Musica]
Esatto esatto
il brano era di Brahms se un tipo
insulso una stridolato un tipo debole
uomini deboli destini deboli
per pezzo verso perverso parola per
parola
devo andare nel laboratorio di arte
Vi prego mandiamo questo video nello
spazio e facciamo sì che sia l'unica
presenza che testimonia la vita sulla
terra Voglio vedere gli alieni cosa
pensano via È finito è finito così è
finito così che cosa mi che Dov'è la
trama Dov'è perché abbiamo buttato un
anno di laboratorio per fare questo cosa
cosa vedo no no no no no no non esiste
Allora ragazzi cioè scusa io io mi
permetto questa documentazione non è
esistita siamo cambiati tanto negli anni
adesso vi faccio vedere faccio una
precisazione Questa è la ragazza che è
quel bambino che era nella scena mia
quello che si appoggia la mia schiena
scrive prima o poi tiro fuori i vecchi
film che abbiamo girato alle medie se ti
ricordi purtroppo mi ricordo pubblica
umiliazione stai tranquillo
ci pensa il sottoscritto questa Eccoci
questo so io Questa è l'altra d e questo
è Gabri che comunque i capelli anche qua
non è che è fantastico ragazzi un film
incredibile una merda va bene ragazzi
Questo video Purtroppo finisce qua
Peccato Eh perché avrei voluto
continuare tutto il giorno ma purtroppo
altre cose migliori da fare tipo farmi
frantumare le palle da una pressa
idraulica però che vi sia piaciuto
iscrivetevi al canale e vivere l'amore
che meraviglia Non è vero l'amore è una
merda Non è vero È una meraviglia
Dipende da che punto lo si guarda
Ciao